bienvenidos de nuevo a economía en
france 24 para hacer este repaso
económico contamos con la ayuda de
nuestro compañero jorge hurtado jorge
buenas noches vamos a comenzar hablando
de los tipos de interés porque se espera
que suban en eeuu así es así lo dijo yo
era un pavo de él es el presidente de la
reserva federal de eeuu y aseguró hoy
que podría haber un aumento más rápido
de lo esperado de los tipos de interés
según powell el banco central está
preparando para subir los tipos de
interés en medio punto porcentual en su
próxima reunión si es necesario hace una
semana la reserva federal subió los
tipos de interés en un cuarto de punto
luego de dos años con los costos sobre
préstamos casi nulos se espera que los
tipos de interés se eleven seis veces
este año y que cierren en un 2% la
subida de los tipos de interés o en la
referencia mundial para los préstamos
por hipotecas los préstamos para
automóviles las tarjetas de crédito y
otros préstamos para consumidores y
empresas
el discurso de powell sonó más jockey o
halcón así se le conoce o así se le
llama en política monetaria a la postura
que privilegia la subida de los tipos de
interés para contener la inflación
mientras que los palomas suelen bajarlos
para fomentar la contratación
eeuu a un no residente el impacto de la
guerra entre rusia y ucrania en su
economía pero tiene la inflación más
alta en 40 años pero el gran dilema
ahora de la reserva federal es que si
sube los tipos de interés demasiado
lento no pueda controlar la inflación
pero si lo hace muy rápido puede
ocasionar un desajuste en los mercados
interesante jorge ya propósito de la
inflación estamos empezando a escuchar
un nuevo término la estanflación a qué
se refieren los economistas bueno así se
le llama cuando se juntan dos fenómenos
económicos la inflación y el
estancamiento de una economía este
término ha resonado desde que inició la
guerra en ucrania con el alza de las
materias primas y la caída de las
perspectivas de crecimiento económico
pero la presidenta del banco central
europeo- christine lagarde dijo que no
prevé un escenario de estanflación
aunque sí de una elevada inflación según
ella a corto plazo el encarecimiento de
la energía y la urgente aceleración de
la transición energética en la unión
europea podría provocar un alza de
precio el banco europeo
el 10 de marzo sus previsiones de
crecimiento para la zona euro y las dejó
en 37 en 2022 frente al 42 por ciento
que había proyectado en diciembre pero
elevó al mismo tiempo sus estimaciones
de inflación al 5,1 por ciento cuando en
diciembre habían dicho que serían del
3,2 por ciento y seguimos con la
actualidad el alza de los precios del
combustible que se está notando ya en
américa latina' iniciamos en cuba y la
gasolinera de la región de matanza y
algunas partes de la habana amanecieron
con largas filas de vehículos por un
posible racionamiento de combustible
según las autoridades la empresa estatal
que suministra combustible a las
estaciones de servicio del país estaba
trabajando con sólo el 62 por ciento de
sus también ese reparto en honduras en
los combustibles aumentarán a partir de
hoy entre 9 y 11 centavos de dólar
allí el galón de gasolina regular
sufrirá un aumento de 7 centavos de
dólar para quedar en 44 dólares según la
nueva estructura de precios el alza de
precios en los combustibles tiene su
repercusión directa en los costos de los
alimentos y por su parte en su vecina
nicaragua el gobierno anunció que
nuevamente los precios de los
combustibles tras siete semanas de alzas
continuas allí los precios rebasan los
cuatro dólares por galón según el diario
de la prensa del gobierno a nicaragua
tiene un margen de casi un dólar para
contener los precios aunque por ahora
las autoridades prometieron que tomarán
medidas no especificaron de cuáles se
trata bueno jorge vamos ahora con los
indicadores de las principales bolsas
mundiales bueno los mercados bursátiles
de todo el mundo cayeron debido a que
los combates en ucrania se prolongaron
sin señales de un alto al fuego wall
street cerró en rojo por las
declaraciones del presidente de la
reserva federal de eeuu que advirtió una
vez más sobre el aumento de la inflación
y prometió tomar medidas en europa la
bolsa alemana cerró con una caída del
0,60 por ciento ante la subida del
precio del petróleo y por la volatilidad
de los mercados de valores y en américa
latina' el de sant y merval de la bolsa
de comercio de buenos aires cerró con
una subida del 1 10 por ciento hasta los
90 mil 41 puntos y vamos a acabar con
las cifras del día que nos trajo la
cifra del 10 61 por ciento de eso
aumento la canasta básica en venezuela
durante un año según el centro de
documentación y análisis social de la
federación venezolana de maestros un
organismo independiente en febrero de
2021 una familia promedio de cinco
integrantes necesitó una media de 282
dólares para alimentación ahora
requieren 173 dólares más que hace un
año para comprar los mismos productos
una subida seguramente insostenible para
muchas familias jorge muchas gracias por
este repaso a nuestros espectadores les
invitamos a que sigan conectados a
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
i